The only prior knowledge you need for
this lesson is a familiarity with the
basics of graphs and graph traverses.
You should know what a graph is and
the difference between directed and
undirected graphs.
You should be familiar with the common
vocabulary surrounding graphs
such as vertex degree.
The ideas of neighbors and
neighborhoods and paths in graphs.
And we will also assume that you are
familiar with the basic graph traversal
algorithms like Depth-first search and
Breadth-first search and
their running times.
The plan for the lesson is this.
We begin by introducing the necessary
definitions for a flow network,
flow capacities, and residual networks,
and residual capacities.
Then, we present
the Ford-Fulkerson method, and
show that it finds a maximum flow with
the help of a theorem that shows that
the maximum flow in a network is
actually equal to the minimum cut.
Finally, we discuss two variations on
the Ford-Fulkerson method, showing
that these algorithms make it much more
efficient than a naive version would be.
This lecture will follow most closely
the treatment in Kleinberg and
Tardos, Algorithm Design, but any
reference on the subject should suffice.